information without emotion is not
retaining our fans are our secret sauce
and that's one of the reasons why I
think we're so successful challenge the
status quo look at things differently
need motivation what to tell me from
elimination
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a woman who started
her WWE career as a model to rising up
through the ranks to becoming chief
brand officer and one of the most
powerful businesswoman in the world
she's Stephanie McMahon and he was my
take on her top ten rules of success
let's kick it off with rule number one
stand out with your story Tony Robbins
has a quote that information without
emotion is not retaining and I think
that that's an important point for any
brand trying to make a connection out
there there's a proliferation of
products and services so why should I
dance Azure consumers care about your
product why can you answer that question
in your marketing and your messaging and
the single best way to relate to an
audience to relate to a person is
through storytelling because stories are
relatable so if you can position your
brand in that way I mean I remember a
commercial since I was a little girl it
was a Polaroid commercial of this little
daughter dancing on her dad's feet and
it goes through as she gets older you
know that same dance and then suddenly
she's a bride dancing on her dad's feet
and I so resonated with that commercial
because it spoke to me you know it was
family and I think that that's one of
the most important pieces of your
communication is to relate to your
audience give them a reason to care rule
number two learn from failures my father
is you know he grew up in abject poverty
he had no running water he always talks
about how the outhouse in North Carolina
he didn't know if it was worse in the
winter or the summer and you can use
your own imagination for why that may be
and he said then he moved uptown into an
eight-foot-wide trailer because it did
have running water and plumbing and all
that good stuff and my dad really lived
the American dream and coming from
humble beginnings to creating a global
Empire because of his vision and because
of his drive and never giving up and
accepting you know mistakes and failures
and learning from them you know I think
that that is a really big part of growth
and oftentimes people see it as setbacks
and that's not what it is you you have
to learn it's a learning opportunity you
know why did it fail
what went wrong what could I have done
differently and then apply that
knowledge you know my dad also always
says intelligence is the application of
knowledge and I completely agree with
that rule number three listen to fans I
think with a massive company like that
it's a twelve billion views online that
you could get to belong on YouTube alone
yeah yeah and that you could you know
you could sit back and think this is so
successful we don't we don't need to
worry too much about oh no you do listen
to the fact yes actually I think that
that's our secret sauce when you think
about Monday Night Raw imagine all of
those fans and all of those families in
the arena and then imagine an empty
arena right our show would be pretty
boring mm-hmm it would lack the energy
it would lack the excitement our fans
are our secret sauce and that's one of
the reasons why I think we're so
successful on social mouth before take
calculated risks WrestleMania is the
event my father created and mortgaged
everything he owned and my mom owned to
make it happen WrestleMania one hmm was
that a turning point the company by the
way absolutely and it was available on
closed-circuit television which
ultimately pioneered the whole
pay-per-view industry Wow
yep yeah and then we were one of the
first to launch our OTT
direct-to-consumer platform behind
Netflix and Hulu
so really you know my father really is a
visionary and in terms of
entrepreneurship his message is always
to take risks but take calculated risks
remember five challenge the status quo
what is the best advice you've ever
gotten professionally professionally
I've gotten so much good advice I think
one of my father who is also the
chairman and CEO of wnv Vince McMahon
his mantra really is to treat each day
like it's the first day on the job you
know challenge the status quo look at
things differently you know come in with
a fresh mind and a fresh perspective as
much as you possibly can and that has
been very valuable advice a lot of times
we get stuck or mired down and the way
we think things are supposed to be done
and I think especially in today's day
and age there are so many fresh young
creative minds coming from all over the
place
and they asked a simple question and you
go oh yeah why don't we go that way
that's that's so much better
rule number six prioritize you are a mom
I am you have three young daughters
right and you're businesswoman and your
character on the show
how do you do you have strategies you
use to navigate all of this stuff plus
you I we're in California now but I know
you're back east - so there's a state
you what I call it big life like so how
do you navigate all about um you know
it's it's challenging right um but I
think it is for for anybody you know I
think it is for women who you know stay
at home or dads to stay at home when you
couple that with traveling and that kind
of thing maybe that's what makes it
different but life is hard for everybody
right and different aspects and I think
the best strategy really is to
prioritize right because my mom taught
me a long time ago
that pendulum is never gonna be in the
middle I agree with it it's always
swinging yes so it's it's not a balance
as you would think it's it it is a
balance in essence but it's always
shifting it's never balance it's never
balanced it's never even and I just do
everything I can me and my husband both
do to maximize our time with our kids to
prioritize each other as well we went on
a date the other night and unfortunately
is like the first date night we've had
in four months over with since before
the holidays so it was special yeah
which we need to do better job there but
you know being there for our kids
putting them down at night taking them
to school in the morning taking them to
school is one of my favorite things to
do the only thing that tops it is
picking them up from school seriously
yeah and sometimes I'll leave work just
to go pick them up just for that
experience just for that and they love
it rule number seven have a mission our
mission is to put smiles on people's
faces the world over and whether we do
that there are entertainment content if
I do that you know for example from the
ring when I see the smiles on people's
faces or when you meet somebody in an
airport and they tell you a story about
how I remember when this have
and it's a smile from ear to ear or when
we have the opportunity to give back
which is a huge part of our business and
something that is a core value for WWE
and you have the chance to meet these
children who often are very
underprivileged and see the looks on
their faces and the smiles that you
bring and the hugs that you get I mean
there's nothing more rewarding than that
so it's such a privilege to represent
this brand and to be a part of WWE
especially as chief brand officer and
the chance to really tell our stories
and spread awareness and you know that
that's what WWE is rule number eight
believe in yourself
what do you know now that you wish you
could have told your younger self mmm
I think to believe in myself more to be
confident and to know my own self-worth
you know that's that's the advice that I
try to give my daughters as well I have
three daughters ages 9 7 and 5 and you
know I think that women in general and
probably men too we go through life with
a lot of insecurities and and that's
where peer pressure falls in and all of
that good stuff so I think that advice I
would want to give my younger self is
just believe in yourself
rule number 9 find your passion when
you're the fourth generation as we said
that new intro of wrestling crater was
there any doubt in your mind that you
were going to go into the family
business
actually no it's what I've always wanted
to do I've always been a fan of
wrestling and WWE in particular and
especially growing up watching my father
who was the chairman CEO and also a
commentator on the show and I was just
in thrall to you know business
conversation at the dinner table and and
listening to the stories that were
getting built in the characters and
meeting them and seeing them actually my
first WWE live event I was about 3 years
old and I went walking backstage and
I'll never forget it all of a sudden
these kids came running at me screaming
terrified and I couldn't imagine what
was happening my parents were down the
hallway and then here comes George the
animal Steele who had basically so much
hair on his back
like fern he his tongue was green and he
was in character lumbering towards me
and I then screamed at the top of my
lungs and virtually ran up my father's
leg and buried my head in his neck okay
but I'd noticed he was laughing my
father the great defender and then he
introduced me to George the animal
Steele who was also known as Jim Myers a
schoolteacher and that was my first
inkling into the world of WWE and rule
number 10 the last home before a very
special bonus clip is have fun it's like
playing a character that's kind of like
a villain all the time yeah he is a
villain right I've been an hour audience
wanted me to be a villain from day one
but they did not like the super sweet
vanilla little daddy's girl it never
worked
is it we hire you to do that or no so
much fun I love being the heel I love it
I love interacting with our audience and
them getting me and me getting them I
mean that's it's all about you know and
you know to me it's way more interesting
and fun too because I change your energy
I'm just curious because I don't get to
ever do that what is your energy change
like when you're done are you still like
kind of that person for an hour
afternoon like you just done
no I can go in and out yeah yeah well
I've been doing it for a long time
yeah a really long time but basically
you know unfortunately there's a lot of
stereotypes in this world right I just
play in to the stereotype okay that's
all I do
right right and and have fun yes I mean
and that's when I think we're at our
best in our business we're having fun
because our audience can feel it when
you talk about the energy yes there is
no greater energy on earth and
interacting with a live crowd of
hundreds of thousands of people like it
is it's gonna be a rush it is amazing
amazing now I've got a special bonus
clip from Stephanie on how to accomplish
goals that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from watching another video to
actually taking action in your business
or in your life and if you're feeling
bold leave your replies in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your mission number two what
status quo are you
LNG and number three what calculated
risk do you need to take
social media you're working out like
midnight it's the only time we have to
trade but you often ask like is there
some type of biological you know like no
there's no advantage I don't recommend
it yeah sleep is important guys just so
you know this woman is crazy just me
we're talking about crazy all alone
we're talking about I mean a totally
devoted mother you can hear on what she
talks about her husband so you're
getting a sense of the relationship
there
this massive enterprise of WWE and then
fitness right because she's a character
on the show too and I'm telling you if
you go to her Instagram here to see
midnight workouts and so even if I was a
character I'd train at midnight what
because it's it's a part of what makes
me me I feel good about myself when I
train I think that the more in shape you
are the more you can do it just in
general I think it clears your mind
training is my church you know and I
think also this is just I don't know I
think human nature I think it is
important to accomplish goals right I
think you feel good about yourself it
builds confidence when you set goals and
you can achieve them and even though
it's a you know it's a set it's a rep
it's whatever it is whatever that goal
is that night no matter how simple it
might be I'm killing my goals you know
what I mean and pushing myself past
where I think I can go and I love that
it's a training is as much a mental
challenge as it as a physical one
totally you know and I love that feeling
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you liked this video and want to
learn how to think big like her father
Vince McMahon check out the video next
to me I think you're gonna enjoy
continue to believe and I'll see you
there my dad was talking about selling
out and that frightened me because I
didn't know if I'd be a part